اعلن في السلطاته في كثبوا عن تبادل
الاطلاق النار بين الشرطه ومهاجمين
مجهولين في ثلاث حوادث منفصله استهدفت
عناصر للشرطه كانت في طريقها الى معبر
برينجك الحدودي مع صربيا جاء ذلك بعد
استهداف الشرطه في تطبيق القانون التابعه
لاتحاد الاوروبي المعروفه بيوليكس بقنبله
صوتيه
في الاتحاد الاوروبي جزء دان الهجوم وحذر
من ان الاتحاد لن يتسامح مع الهجمات على
بعثهوليكس او مع العنف والاعمال الاجراميه
الرئيس الصربي الكسندر الذي يدرك ان
بلادهم اتهمتهم بالوقوف وراءنا يجري في
شمال
تسعى الى تهدئه الوضع في شمال القصبه لكنه
طالب باطلاق سراح السير بالمعتقلين
الذين ضدهم على الاطلاق
شخص ما نصب حواجز انه احتجاج على سوء
المعامله اليوميه للسكان الصرب الاحتجاج
على عدم الوفاء بالتزامات اتفاق بروكسل
المانيا التي دانت على اللسان وزيره
خارجيتها انا لينا بيربوك الهجوم على بعثه
الاتحاد الاوروبي ورفضت اقتراح صربيا
رساله قوات الى كوسوفو كان لها نصيب من
تصريحات الرئيس الصربيه
حتى قبل ان نرسل الرساله
من جانبه قال رئيس وزراء كوسوفو البن
كورتي ان بلاده تريد السلام لكنها سترد
على اي عدوان بكل ما اوتيت من قوه
توالت ردود الافعال على مجريات الاحداث
شمال كسفه حيث عبرت الولايات المتحده وعبر
سفارتيها في البلدين عن قلقها من التطورات
ودانه الهجمات على الشرطه الكسوفيه ودوريه
الاتحاد الاوروبي ودعت الى ضبط النفس
واتخاذ اجراءات للتهدئه
بدوره ده انا حلف الناتو الهجوم على شرطه
الاتحاد الاوروبي وطالب بمحاسبه مسؤولين
ودعا الجميع الى تجنب الاعمال والخطابات
لاستفزازيه الازمه الحاليه بين البلدين
بدات بطلب سلطات قصفه استبدال لوحات
السيارات القادمه من صربي المجاوره
بلاوحات صادره عن السلطات في قصصه لكن
التوتر المزمن يتعلق باعلان كتفه
استقلالها عن صربيا عام 2008 وهو ما لا
تعترف به بالاكراد وتشجع الاغلبيه في شمال
كوزوفو على تحدي السلطات هناك